err veterans prophecy from millennium
past there were two types of Arabs city
dwellers and veterans veterans are
nomads they travel through the vast
deserts and are constantly on the move
even during the Golden Age of Islam when
Arabs were the richest and most learned
people on earth better ones remained in
virtually the same state that they had
been for thousands of years poor
uneducated and cut off from the rest of
the world yet Muhammad peace be upon him
foretold that these Arab Bedouin zuv his
region would one day compete with one
another in the construction of tall
buildings now tell me of the last hour
asked the man
the Prophet replied that you see the
barefoot unclothed better wins competing
in the construction of tall buildings
today we find in the Arabian Peninsula
the better ones who used to be
impoverished herders of camels and sheep
are now not only competing with one
another but also the entire world to
construct the world's tallest buildings
how did one of the poorest people on
earth who literally wore rags become the
wealthiest nations on earth one thing
that made this rapid change possible was
the discovery of oil the seemingly empty
deserts of the veterans had it in
abundance
they went from camels to Cadillacs in a
single generation the construction of
tall buildings among the Arab edwin's
has even reached Mecca Muhammad city of
birth the last few decades have seen a
massive surge in building construction
in Mecca the famous Mecca clock tower is
currently the third tallest building in
the world in order for such construction
to be possible many of mecca's ancient
mountains had to be demolished in order
to make room for the tall buildings that
had sprung up
amazingly this is also something that
Muhammad had foretold
he said the hour will not be established
until the mountains are moved from their
places this tremendous feat of
demolishing entire mountains has only
been made possible in the 20th century
with the advent of technology such as
explosives it's important to point out
that Muhammad himself was a simple man
and wanted other Muslims to maintain
that simplicity he did not like Muslims
to be extravagant so if he wanted to
will this prophecy to become true he
would have to encourage the Arabs to
build tall buildings yet he never did
the spread of sexual immorality and
disease Muhammad peace be upon him
revealed that the day of judgement would
not take place until sexual immorality
had become so prevalent and normalized
that it would begin to be carried out
even in public places
he said the hour will not be established
until people fornicate with each other
in the road just as donkeys fornicate
today we live in a world where we are
being constantly bombarded with explicit
sexual imagery be it in TV film or
advertising and with the advent of the
internet pornography has now become
readily available at any time in any
place in fact we are finding more and
more stories in the news of people being
arrested for having sex in public and an
interesting side note is that the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
described what will be the consequences
of such widespread sexual immorality
he said never does sexual perversion
become widespread and publicly known in
certain people without them being
overtaken by disease that never happened
to their ancestors who came before them
the increase of sexual immorality has
seen the emergence of previously
unheard-of diseases such as AIDS just as
the Prophet Muhammad cat for warrant
a world steeped in interest Muhammad
peace be upon him claimed that the
practice of interest would one day
become so dominant that even those who
try to avoid it will still feel its
impact he said a time will come upon
mankind when they will consume interest
whoever does not take from it will be
afflicted by its dust this clearly
describes the state of the world's
economy today in the modern world it is
almost impossible to avoid dealing with
where at the very least being impacted
by interest just think about how many
people have interest-bearing bank
accounts and buy things using credit
cards even if one somehow manages to
avoid dealing and interest directly
almost every aspect of our lives is
impacted by it central bank's influence
the purchasing power of our money and
virtually every country in the world
even those considered to be wealthy are
drowning an interest-based debt the
financial system even suffered a global
collapse in 2008 the disaster which had
plunged the world into economic turmoil
the consequences of which will be felt
for generations to come
what makes this prediction amazing is
that the financial state of the world
over the last century is unique in
history at the time of Muhammad finance
was based on commodities with intrinsic
value such as gold and silver coins gold
and silver have been used as the most
common form of currency throughout
history the use of paper money with no
intrinsic value along with the massive
debt and interest that has resulted in
is a phenomenon of modern finance and
not something that could have been
easily guessed by Muhammad over 1,400
years ago the defeat of Rome in the
conquest of Persia
during the Battle of the trench where
Muhammad peace be upon him and his
followers were under siege by their
enemies being outnumbered three-to-one
and staring in the face of certain
defeat the Prophet made some bold
predictions he said God is most great I
have been given the keys of Syria by God
I can see it's red palaces at the moment
God is most great I had been given
Persia God is most great I have been
given the keys of Yemen at that moment
Muhammad have made the astonishing claim
that the Muslims will not only take the
lands of Yemen in Syria much of which
was under the occupation of the Roman
Empire but that they would also defeat
the mighty Persian Empire historically
Muhammad's companions saw this prophecy
fulfilled before their very eyes as they
went on to defeat the Romans in conquer
Persia what are the odds that the
Muslims who lacked economic and military
strength could topple the superpowers of
the world in such a short span of time
the astonishing way that the Muslims
defeated the superpowers captured the
world by surprise as historian Barnaby
Rogerson explains you have to remember
that the two great superpowers were the
Byzantine Empire ie the Eastern Roman
Empire and Sassanid Persia they were the
dominant superpowers if you're putting
it in a modern parlance it's a bit like
the Eskimos taking on the United States
of America in Russia a no rational
person would have ever conceived as such
a possibility the sentiment is echoed by
historians who cannot explain how Islam
became such a dominant force so quickly
professor of Byzantine studies and
rule-out wrote the speed with which the
eastern provinces of the Byzantine
Empire succumbed to the Arabs remains to
be explained by historians
prevalence of writing many of us take
for granted their ability to read and
write in the abundance of books that are
available in the modern age however for
the people of the past illiteracy was
the norm and books were very scarce
Muhammad peace be upon him was born into
a society in which very few people could
read or write it is estimated that the
number of people who were literate in
his locality of Western Saudi Arabia did
not exceed 17 Muhammad himself could not
read or write against this backdrop the
Prophet Muhammad made the prediction
that rightie will one day become
widespread among mankind he said ahead
of the hour the pen will prevail the
Arabic word use for pen here is sanam
which also carries the wider meaning of
writing this perfectly describes our
world today in which it is the norm for
people to read and write and there is an
abundance of books newspapers and
magazines this has only been made
possible thanks to 15th century
technological advances such as printing
that took place over 800 years after
Muhammad's prophesy and with the advent
of the internet writing is spreading
even more anybody with a computer or
smartphone now has access to millions of
books with just the click of a finger
it's quite powerful that Muhammad who
could neither read nor write
prophecies the spread of reading and
writing the greening of Arabia's deserts
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
made a bold prediction about the future
state of Arabia he said the hour will
not begin until the land of the Arabs
once again become meadows and rivers
this narration anticipated the greening
of Arabia's extensive dry desert
environment as recently as 1986 there
was little to no farming in the region
however over the last thirty years these
deserts have been transformed to grow
grain
fruits and vegetables thanks to
techniques such as center pivot
irrigation this is a process that pumps
water to the surface from deep
underground reserves some of which date
back to the last ice age 20,000 years
ago now put yourself in the position of
a person living in seventh century
Arabia this region hosts some of the
most extensive sand and gravel deserts
in the world with very little rainfall
could anyone inhabiting such a harsh
environment have irrationally conceived
the possibility that one day there would
be a plentiful supply of water and
abundant crops this prophecy also makes
a claim about the ancient past note the
words of Muhammad the lands of the Arabs
once again become meadows and rivers by
saying once again he is implying that at
one stage in their history the deserts
were lush with vegetation in life and
that they will be returning to this
former state geologists now know that
the Arabian Peninsula was indeed once
filled with metals and rivers in ancient
times modern archaeological discoveries
have been covered a number of fossils
and conclude that once upon a time
Arabian Peninsula's much greener and
wetter just as Muhammad had revealed
the rapid spread of Islam and the
decline of the Muslims Muhammad peace be
upon him predicted that the Islamic
civilization would reach both east and
west
he said God folded the earth for me and
I saw its East and West and the Dominion
of my nation will reach as far as the
earth was folded for me history bears
witness to the fact that Islam spread
rapidly both east and west
just as Muhammad boldly had foretold at
the time this was a geographic expansion
the likes of which the world had never
witnessed the Islamic empire was the
largest the world had ever seen
the Prophet Muhammad not only informed
us about the spectacular rise of the
Muslims he also foretold their decline
he said the nations will call each other
and set upon you just as dinars set upon
food someone then asked will it be
because of our small number that day the
Prophet Muhammad replied rather on that
day will be many but you will be like
foam like the foam on the river here we
can see that Muhammad prophesized the
dire circumstances in which the Muslims
would find themselves
he explained that a day would come in
which the Muslims would be large a
number but in such a state of weakness
that other nations would invite one
another to set upon them the analogy of
Muslims being eaten as a meal was given
which emphasizes just how helpless they
would become this prediction accurately
describes the radical turn of events
that took place in the Muslim world in
the 19th and 20th century prior to this
the Muslim lands had grown to become
some of the most powerful in the world
from the time of the death of Muhammad
into the 19th century the Muslims were
economically politically militarily and
technologically far ahead of most of the
world
the unthinkable happened nearly all the
Muslim world was occupied colonized and
militarily defeated by non-muslim
Nations
Russia had annexed the caucus France
controlled Algeria Morocco and Tunisia
Great Britain occupied Egypt Syria Iraq
Palestine in India and the Dutch
controlled Malaysia and Indonesia of the
50 Muslim countries that exist today
only a few survived occupation and the
ones that did were still subject to
colonial masters all of this is just as
the Prophet Mohammed had predicted at
the time there was an estimated 200
million Muslims representing 12.5
percent of the world's population but
their considerable numbers could do
nothing to prevent the defeat by their
rivals they were weak like the foam on a
river again just as Muhammad as foretold
if we reflect on this prediction it is
quite counterintuitive if this
prediction was guesswork then it would
have made more sense to state that the
Muslims would be diminished in number
and that would be the cause of their
weakness yet Muhammad predicted the
exact opposite a paradoxical situation
of the Muslims being vast a number but
very weak and it came true historically
speaking when religions lose their
influence on the world stage in such a
way it is usually followed by a
stagnation or decline in the number of
their followers yet Muhammad foretold
the exact opposite with regards to the
religion of Islam he said that it would
continue to grow in terms of the number
of followers to the extent that it would
eventually enter every household he said
this matter will certainly reach every
place touched by night and day God will
not leave a house or residence except
that God will cause this religion to
enter it today we are witnessing this
prophecy unfold before our very eyes
oh um is currently the fastest growing
religion in the world with nearly 1 in 4
people on earth being a Muslim and is
forecasted to be the world's largest
religion by the Year 2070 this is
despite Islam being constantly attacked
by the media
the colonisation of Muslim lands and the
many Wars that had been waged in the
Muslim world
even the name Mohammed has prophetic
implications it's an Arabic word that
means the praised one the Quran states
how Muhammad's remembrance will be
raised we elevated your mention for you
since this verse was revealed over 1400
years ago the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him has been the most praised
person in history today not a second
goes by without a minaret somewhere in
the world publicly proclaiming the time
for prayer insane
[Music]
I bear witness that Muhammad is the
Messenger of God
[Music]
Oh
moreover the name Muhammad is
consistently the most popular name given
to newborns across the globe this is
despite the fact that Muhammad never
encouraged Muslims to adopt his name in
fact he said that the best names are
Abdullah and Abdul Rahman
now we've analyzed the number of the
prophet muhammad's prophecies which were
made over 1400 years ago and have seen
how he has accurately foretold many
things
purely from the standpoint of basic
probability for someone to accurately
guess about such future events which
spanned across multiple nations in
different time periods many of which
were outside the sphere of Muslim
influence to give so many predictions
without making a single mistake is
utterly impossible today millions of
people believe in false prophets and
follow false systems for guidance in
life as human beings balloon to follow
false prophets and mate systems and
baseless superstitions but why don't we
accept the real guidance when it comes
from God God empowered the Prophet
Mohammed with accurate prophecies as a
way for us to distinguish the true
prophets from the false truth has now
arrived in falsehood perished for
falsehood is by its nature bound to
perish this video is based on the book
the forbidden prophecies to learn more
about the evidences for Muhammad's
prophethood please download your FREE
copy of the book at the link below